deux mois n'auront pas suffi à effacer
le choc qu'ont vécu steven et sa femme
ils sont propriétaires de cet hôtel
depuis une trentaine d'années jamais ils
n'ont vu la nature se déchaîne et à ce
point
nous sommes montés sur le toit c'est
venu si vite comme un raz-de-marée
aujourd'hui le couple qui approchaient
de la retraite doit tout reconstruire
mais avant il faut encore démolir
la semaine prochaine nous allons démolir
la moitié de l'hôtel avant de
reconstruire mais plus petit
et liens de transport sont toujours
coupées mais ceux de la communauté sont
plus soudés que jamais
il y a beaucoup de gens qui travaillent
bénévolement toute la semaine dernière
et cette fin de semaine on avait des
gens qui ont travaillé sans rien
demander
chacun ici et c'est de se rendre utile
repas gratuit une gare transformée
centre de don l'entr'aide se dévoile au
fil des gravats qui envahissent encore
rue
mathias a été épargné par la crue
soudaine mais ils restent profondément
marqués par ce qu'il a vu son village en
durée
un
peu pour panser les plaies de ses
voisins de derna il s'est engagé auprès
de la ddt état d'esprit manetti une ong
qu'on a plutôt l'habitude de croiser
dans les pays en voie de développement
il coordonne le pré d'outils et de
machinerie pour que chacun puisse se
reconstruire ils ont été aux yeux du
jour au lendemain avec cette crise les
gens sont devenus très pauvre le
lendemain de la catastrophe je marchais
ici dans les rues de mon village
complètement détruit et j'ai croisé des
personnages et encore en pyjama un sac à
la main avec au mieux un tee shirt de
recharge ici toi ils n'avaient rien
d'autre plus rien c'était tout ce qui
leur restait mais a pu me ramener chez
eux même si nenê semeur on ne voit plus
que les dégâts matériels des inondations
du moins au premier coup d'oeil et
mathias c'est que les ravages vont bien
au delà des maisons emportées par la
lame d'eau et de boue cloche
rigueur d'hébreu l'allemagne beaucoup
d'argent et c'est sûr que les ponts et
les voies ferrées vont être reconstruits
mais les ménages doivent absolument
garder l'espoir toucher rapidement de
l'argent parce qu'un pont ou une voie de
chemin de fer peut il ne risque pas de
se suicider ici à derna on a déjà eu
trois suicides et des tentatives qu'on a
pu heureusement évité on en est
maintenant à 150 morts et ce sont 152
trop le plan
j'ai perdu deux amis elles ont été
surprises par l'inondation
alors qu'elle dormait
elles seront coeur
comme beaucoup ici manuela ne cherche
pas à rebâtir avec de la brique et du
mortier mais tous les jours elle enfile
ses bottes et empoigne s'appelle pour
éviter de sombrer à la suite des
disparus
j'ai retourné la terre d'un parterre de
fleurs pendant deux jours avec une pelle
et j'ai déterré des fleurs qui était
encore enfouies sous les boues de
l'inondation puis je les ai planté comme
symbole que si ces fleurs là peuvent
survivre
nous aussi nous avons une chance de
avec l'ampleur de la dévastation mais
surtout de tout ce qui reste à
reconstruire la majorité des habitants
dans la région vous diront qu'ils ont
autre chose à faire que de penser à la
politique et aux élections
le jour des inondations willem geller
était en train de vider sa maison pour
la léguer à son fils et sa jeune famille
mais les deux hommes se sont retrouvés
coincés au dernier étage alors que l'eau
et la boue faisait leur oeuvre
destructrice commodesk en des fois je
jouais monte tellement vite jusque tout
là haut si on se penchait de la fenêtre
on pouvait toucher l'eau avec la main
face mais theron dans ce bassin à 70 ans
lui qui avait bâti cette maison pièce
par pièce de ses mains il ya 25 ans doit
tout recommencer il devra attendre
jusqu'à avril prochain pour que tout
soit sécher avant de pouvoir lui rendre
son charme ce que je redoute ce sont de
nouvelles inondations ça risque de se
reproduire de plus en plus souvent et je
crains que du côté de la politique on ne
prenne pas de mesures suffisantes pour
empêcher sa faveur wilhelm n'a aucune
intention d'aller voter pour élire un
nouveau chancelier ou une nouvelle
chancelière ce dimanche ce militant
écologiste de la première heure ne pas
plus que la solution viendra des
dirigeants
depuis que j'ai 16 17 ans je m'intéresse
énormément à la politique
les déclarations sont toujours les mêmes
et ne débouchent sur rien ma en tout cas
pas sur ce qui devrait être fait c'est
très frustrant
ça ne répare pas tout mais pour tout ce
qu'ils ont perdu de matériel de visu
humaine et d'idéaux les communautés de
la rhénanie honte à tout le moins gagné
la certitude qu'ils seront là les uns
pour les autres
ici marie ève bédard radio-canada en
rhénanie